is the 15-in MacBook Air worth buying
now that we have the new M3 series
MacBooks well I think so and I'll
explain exactly why but the first one is
that you can get it for
$1,050 I'll have the link down below and
that in my opinion is the best value
MacBook ever now we have had a few of
these for 6 months now and I been
actually asking for a system like this 4
years before Apple released it and that
is because this is the first large
screen MacBook that doesn't cost an arm
and a leg for years if you wanted to
have a large display like this 15in
Intel system you would have to spend
$2,400 or
$2,500 and that's out of the price range
of most people now of course we have had
13-in systems like this one but when you
look at the screen size side by side it
is a massive difference now along with
that we also have differences in
performance even though though both
these have M2 chips the 15-in one comes
with an unbin chip that has quite a bit
better graphics performance and along
with that it actually has better
sustained performance as well because of
the larger chassis now right now there's
a lot of hype with the M3 $1600 14in
MacBook and when we tested it the 8 gigs
of RAM is a huge limitation so even
though the M3 chip does have more
performance it's not a massive
difference and one thing that a lot of
us reviewers kind of forget when we do
these kind of comparisons is that a lot
of people are going to be coming from an
older Intel base Mac or a Windows
computer and this system right here
costs about $4,000 when I bought it and
looking at the performance the 15in M2
air smokes it in so many ways even in
real world tougher tasks like photo
editing now with that the battery life
is also quite a bit smaller than that
machine but the battery life that you
get with light tasks is double and then
if you do push it hard it has actually
triple the battery life because of how
much less power the new Apple silicon
chips use with that there's also a low
power mode that allows it to sit power
and get up to 22 hours of battery life
in this system and even though sizewise
they are very similar and they both have
15in display place other than the
MacBook Air having that Notch with a
little bit more vertical head room it is
a lot lighter and it is thinner as well
and let me tell you guys using this
15-in air taking it on the go is such a
pleasure because the 14-in M3 version is
a lot thicker it is heavier and even
though the footprint is a little bit
smaller it feels much more bulky need
access to all of your systems while on
the go with pulseway you can centrally
control all of your it systems like like
desktop servers and network devices
allowing you to remotely connect to a
system run a script reset a password or
simply shut your system down and best of
all it works from literally any device
like your iPhone iPad and laptop so you
can have full control while on the go so
check out pulseway holiday special
offers through the link down below and
secure the Limited Time pricing by
starting a trial now a lot of people
have said that the M3 14in with 8 gigs
of RAM is designed for people that just
want to use email web browsing watching
some vide
but the 15in air does it just as well
and it's
$1,050 such a killer value and I will
say that using this for typing and those
kind of tasks is actually nicer because
of how thin it is The Edge doesn't dig
into your wrists and I absolutely love
that now we do have some differences in
terms of ports with this 14-in we have
the HDMI and we have a SD card reader
but one thing you need to keep in mind
is that this M3 system also only
supports One external display and I
think that for most regular users that
is just fine it starts to matter more if
you start upgrading it maybe getting a
better processor and a 14in now another
thing that is great about these new
systems compared to the previous Intel
ones is that you don't just have USB
type-c ports we also have a MAG safe so
it keeps the other two Thunderbolt ports
available and because of that you can
also get a cheap little dock like this
it does suck to have a dongle but you'll
get a lot more ports than you will in a
14in model now the 15-in display is
perfect I think it's the best allaround
size and it is nice and sharp um it has
pretty good brightness it's a great
display now you're not going to get the
super bright xdr which is great if you
want to watch HDR movies or you want to
work with HDR files but then again for
most people that are buying this kind of
system that won't be that big of a deal
and upgrading from an Intel based system
one thing that you're going to love is
that it is fanless so even though it can
heat up and it can slow down a little
bit it doesn't slow down too much and
there's no dust that's going to get
inside there's no noise like you will
get with your older MacBook now another
thing that I love about the 15-in
compared to the 13-in systems is the
speaker system apple is able to pack in
a six speaker system into it and even
compared to the similar generation M2 it
sounds a lot better and it's louder go
ahead and take a
[Music]
listen now I personally really
appreciate that extra volume and sound
and while it does not sound as good as
the much thicker 14inch it is good
enough for most people you just get a
little bit more base with the 14-in
model go ahead and listen to this
[Music]
one now another great thing about the
air is its webcam that is inside of that
Notch the quality looks nice the
processing is a little bit updated so
it's much better than previous MacBooks
and it's good enough for most people and
with that like I said before the
performance that you get compared to
even an M3 it is still more than good
enough and most people are be buying it
will not have any complaints now we have
previously covered the fact that it has
a slower 256 gig SSD compared to some
older M1 machines and that will make a
difference if you do a lot of
productivity but for the people that are
searching around for a value all-around
laptop that is not going to make a
massive difference you can upgrade a 16
and that will help but if you're not
pushing your system hard and you're
upgrading from an older Intel based
system even the base one you can get for
$1,050 right now is going to be great
and from all the machines that we have
out right now for regular users that are
going to use it for regular tasks this
thing is an absolutely insane
value so after 6 months even though
these things did not sell as well when
they came out because of other laptops
coming out um I think this is the one to
buy and that's why I've been
recommending it to a lot of people that
have been reaching out you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section below go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe and check out
one of those great videos right over
there this been Max and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one